john prosser just surprised us with an
exclusive
first look at the redesigned ipad mini 6
on his new website frontpagetag.com
and from the looks of the renders
created by ian's elbow
everything looks pretty legit to me so
in this video
i'm gonna go through each little detail
that he leaked and discuss
how and why it makes sense for apple to
do and then give you guys my thoughts on
when it could potentially be coming
first off i do want to mention that john
got his info from multiple sources
including leaked schematics cad files
and real hands-on images
of the redesigned mini so this isn't
just a guess or anything like that
so let's get right into those renders
alright so i've got my m1 ipad pro right
here and in this first image
we can see the ipad mini 6 on top the
new one
and the current ipad air 4 on the bottom
and from the looks of it they share
the same design so it looks like the
mini is getting the same redesign as the
air already has
but if we take a closer look you can see
that the mini
now gets the new wireless magnetic
charger for the apple pencil which is
very interesting and i don't know if you
guys can tell but if you look at it
the one on the air is actually quite a
bit wider
but don't worry about that because if
you take a look at the ipad pro's
wireless magnetic charger
it is actually quite a bit thinner than
the one on the air
so i'm not sure why apple made it so
thick on the new ipad air and as far as
the new mini this essentially means that
it's going to support
the new apple pencil 2 so you no longer
have to worry about plugging it into
that lightning port to charge
which was very annoying that's
definitely a good sign
and of course these new renders and
leaks from john perfectly match up
to what mark german from bloomberg said
recently
that the ipad mini is going to have
narrower screen borders
with the removal of the home button
which was expected and now moving on to
this image this is where it starts to
get very
very interesting with a few different
details
first of all if you look at that camera
bump it looks essentially
identical to the one that's on the
macbook air
and on top of that we have that mic
right next to it on the side whereas on
the air
it's below it so it looks like it's
getting the same exact specs in terms of
the rear cameras
but the absolutely crazy thing from this
render is that apparently the ipad mini
6 is getting
the smart connector which it has never
had
before and this is really weird because
the ipad mini has
never had the smart connector on the
back and that's because the mini is so
small that it can't really support
regular keyboard cases even the one on
the 11 inch ipad pro
is scrunched down compared to the full
size 12.9 inch model so
i don't know how apple is gonna pull off
a keyboard case on mini
unless this is for something else so i
don't know it's going to be very
interesting
one random thought that i'm having is
that what if apple is going to use that
smart connector
for charging and maybe what if that
smart connector
makes it on the back of the next iphone
to use with a brand new charger that
kind of just tacks onto the back
that also supports all of the ipad pros
because i don't know if you know this or
not
but the magic keyboard case supports
full speed charging
through the smart connector with that
new hinge but anyway
moving on to this next image we can see
that the mini is getting basically the
same edge to edge display
with the rounded corners the same as on
the
air but the interesting detail to notice
is that the bezels
are definitely slimmer on the mini which
is nice
and it totally makes sense because if
they were the same size the display
would look really weird especially for
that small of a size and this actually
makes me think that the next ipad
air is gonna have the same slim bezels
as the mini
because i don't know if you know this
but back in 2019
the 10.5 inch ipad air 3 received the
same
thin bezels on the sides matching the
ones on the mini and as for this new
mini 6
you should expect the display to remain
basically the same
probably including the same resolution
since the pixels per inch on the current
mini
is already much higher than their 264
pixels per inch goal for their ipad
displays
now moving on according to john prosser
he says that the ipad mini 6's new
dimensions
are going to be three millimeters longer
and three millimeters
wider while keeping the thickness
exactly the same so this is essentially
going to allow the display to get much
larger
which mecha thinks is going to be around
8.5
to 9 inches on the new mini and moving
on as expected
touch id is being built into the power
button
just like it is on the ipad air 4 and
because of the smaller size of the mini
it's probably going to be easier to use
compared to the air but in my opinion
face id on the ipad pro is much much
better
but of course apple's going to be
keeping that as an exclusive feature
just for the pros and here is the weird
part there are no speaker grills on the
top
of the ipad mini 6 like there are on the
ipad ear 4. so we asked john about this
on twitter and he confirmed
that the speakers will only be on the
bottom
which is very frustrating because we
know that it's not getting
full stereo sound when you hold it in
landscape mode but nevertheless
jon says that his sources say that the
speakers are
crazy nice even if they're only gonna be
on the bottom
which sounds a bit weird to me but i
guess in reality
since the ipad mini is so small there's
probably a limited amount of space on
the inside
for those extra speakers now moving on
to the next image we have the bottom
which shows those speaker grilles
and apparently a new usb-c port which is
awesome and it totally makes sense
because
when apple redesigned the ipad air 4
they gave it usbc
so it makes sense for the ipad mini as
well and that's going to give you access
to a bunch of docs
adapters and of course it's a much
better porn and this
right here is very interesting john's
sources say that the ipad mini 6 is
going to be coming in silver
gold and black not space gray
but black so that's going to be
interesting to see and right here we can
see the apple pencil support which the
mini has
but one interesting detail he says is
that there was an apple pencil 3
leak a few months ago but he compared
that leaked image to the size of the
current apple pencil
and he's showing that the new apple
pencil is
a little bit shorter and that actually
makes total sense for the mini
because if you think about it the
current apple pencil 2
is almost the same length of the current
ipad
mini which is very funny so a shorter
apple pencil makes total sense
but then going even further john thinks
that this might actually be
the new apple pencil 3 that's meant for
all of the ipads
and if you think about it the current
apple pencil does
seem unnecessarily long so making it a
bit shorter
wouldn't be that big of a deal and on
top of that it's going to make it much
easier for younger kids and students to
use compared to the current apple pencil
but based on all of those leaked details
and the renders made by ian zelbo
we can actually do some extra analysis
to figure out some more details like the
potential release date
the price and some more of the specs so
since the new mini 6 seems to be
essentially a smaller version of the
ipad air 4
right down to the camera bump the design
and of course the display we can almost
certainly expect
a lot of the specs to match up and we
know that because in 2019
the ipad air 3 and the ipad mini 4 were
essentially
identical in terms of the specs and
features apart from the smart connector
so if we look at the specs of the latest
ipad air 4 we should expect the new mini
to get 64 gigs of storage at the base
price
the same touch id power button the same
20 watt usbc power adapter
all of the same display features the
same 12 megapixel camera on the back
the same 7 megapixel camera on the front
and the same wi-fi 6 support with
bluetooth 5.0
but according to john he says that it's
going to be coming with 5g
cellular support which isn't currently
on the air 4
so that means that apple might actually
update some of the other specs as well
and right here john says that the new
mini is going to be getting the a14 chip
which makes total sense because the ipad
air 4 currently has the a14
and originally i thought that it
wouldn't make sense at all for the mini
to come
later this year because apple is going
to be revealing the new a15 ship
in the new iphone 13. so it would be
weird for the mini to get released
after that with the previous gen chip
but then i did a little bit of digging
and i found that every single ipad mini
except for the second generation model
in 2013
received a chip one generation older
than the iphone that was released that
same year
and the reason the 2013 ipad mini got
the same a7 chip as the iphone 5s
is probably because the a7 was the very
first
64-bit chip to be used in a smartphone
which was a very big deal for apple so
with that said
a14 on the ipad mini 6 makes total sense
and jon's sources say that it's going to
be coming by the end of this year
which also makes sense because in the
past most of the ipad minis were
revealed
in the fall and as far as the price tag
i personally think that it's going to be
starting at 499
simply because the fact that apple
raised the ipad air force price
by 100 bucks last year up to 599 dollars
and it was totally justified because of
the new redesign
at least from apple's perspective so
that ended up leaving a nice little gap
for the mini to also get a price jump up
to 499 bucks
and that means that the regular ipad 9
will also get bumped up to probably
around 399 dollars
when it eventually gets the full
redesign but based on all of these
details and renders
i have a pretty good feeling that the
ipad mini 6 is going to be
very popular even with a higher price
tag
and i think we can for sure expect it to
get released
between september and november so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you
in the next video